you are Mary the housekeeper he's told
me of you
some creatures must go back to the
violets here's Monsieur Trapani smashes
them with his stick at night and they
know to stay away from our bed
he does have dominion over all as his
wife I will never need you to serve my
needs help me see to the house that I
may improve the estate and have it do
well on the way to prospering so that
our children may in turn enjoy the
bounty of this land
you will bear him no children I am the
lady of the house I steer the man in
time I will steer him any way I want to
renovate toss out old habits back into
the forest where they belong
[Applause]
there is my dear husband
I was out searching for seven I found
something Murray these seem to have run
away from my sanctum what do you know
about this nothing and must just sell he
told his departed that I go away for one
day my Dahmer falls to disorder you saw
nothing at all as a housekeeper you
should be aware of the comings and
goings on the estate a dog could do
better perhaps you can discover what has
happened to monsieur sell I will speak
alone with men Assad
No I see now the arrangement she was too
designed for yourself I have made no
such design by Sheree
I wish to do only beautiful things in
this dome and you will be my partner in
this and as my partner you will learn to
look past my many flaws and I will look
past your shortcomings which I'm sure a
few did you know that I sailed across an
ocean and walked into the endless
forests that I could find the correct
man to bestow my Maidenhead on that is
no small thing there are deeper bindings
towards which we must work The Binding
of the two will be no more binding nor
any more bedding until you tell me the
truth I gave it once I may never give it
again which choice is this there are so
many floating about black one for me and
I will tear it Murray yes you have lain
with her what would you have me do you
have given her a son did she tell you
that no one need to tell me a thing I
have eyes a brain they will know when
you're going to visit her cabin and when
you have not we will have a proper
wedding ceremony I will wear a special
dress there will be dancing yes of
course we will have in one little
ceremony now I am premium with ideas on
how to improve the DOMA you spoke true
of its beauty but it must be tamed not
everything will lay down for you many
son this is my DOMA and as its master I
must ride it with vigor and authority
stride any way you like with us much
bigger as you may master but you visit
Mary's cabin at your own barrel
[Music]